[MUSIC PLAYING]
CARTER MORGAN: Welcome
to another episode
of "VM End to End," a show
where we have a VM skeptic
and a VM enthusiast
come together,
hash out all things cloud,
computer, compute-related.
Brian, thank you so much
for being here today.
I've got some questions for you.
BRIAN DORSEY: Hello, hello.
I'm excited today.
Databases and VMs,
it's my happy place.
And because of that,
I wanted to bring
in Gabe Weiss, who's
one of our colleagues
and expert in databases.
Hi, Gabe.
GABE WEISS: Hey, everybody.
CARTER MORGAN: Yes,
happy to get into it.
I guess, I'm just going to
dive right in, if that's cool.
I want to know, when it
comes to data on the Cloud
with compute and
whatnot, why not
just let a managed service
run it for me magically?
Why would I want
to run the database
level at the compute level?
Why does that make sense?
GABE WEISS: I mean,
why not, indeed, right?
The dev answer that we
always give, it depends.
There is nothing wrong
with running a database
on a VM in the Cloud.
Let's be clear right away.
Cloud SQL, which is a relational
database managed offering,
it runs in a VM.
So whether you're running
in your VM or our VM,
you're still running in a VM.
The difference is, and why
you might want to run your own
really comes down to
one of requirements.
If you have a legacy
system, you've
got an application you've
been running forever,
and it has a set
of requirements,
then a managed database
might not satisfy those.
One of the things
with managed databases
is we manage it for you,
which means we restrict
what you can do with it, right?
BRIAN DORSEY: OK, so
let's be specific.
What are the kinds
of things that
might push you into running
it yourself on a VM?
GABE WEISS: Right.
So I bring up-- like, if
you've got this legacy
system, if you've got an
application that you've
been running for a
couple of decades,
it builds up over time-- what
you add to it, when you have
requirements, what you need.
So a real good concrete
example of this
is, take SQL Server, one of
the big things with SQL servers
are stored procedures.
You've got these methods that
run on the database itself.
Stored procedures have certain
requirements sometimes.
Like, maybe they
require a super user.
If you're running on
a managed database,
we don't give you
a proper super user
because we have to protect
the database for you.
We have an SLA, a
Service Level Agreement,
where we guarantee that
the database is going
to be up all the time for you.
You hear some people
talk about the nines.
The nines is your percent of
how much uptime we guarantee.
Cloud SQL, for example,
our managed offering,
is 99.95% available--
3 and 1/2 nines,
which means it's
like 20 minutes of downtime a
month or something like that.
So with these extensions,
or the stored procedures,
we have to guard that
uptime, which means
we don't give you everything.
So if you've got a system
that requires that,
a managed system might
not work for you.
CARTER MORGAN: OK.
That actually makes
a lot of sense.
And I appreciate you for
bringing in that perspective.
So now, my question
is, what about someone
that maybe doesn't have
their database in the Cloud
yet but they're thinking
about switching over?
What's the process for that?
GABE WEISS: Right.
So you're talking about-- we
call it the green field, where
new application, a new
company that's thinking,
like, where should
I put my stuff?
Everything's moving
to the Cloud.
Let's be clear.
This what we're seeing
in the industry,
is everyone wants
their data in the Cloud
for a whole host of reasons.
You want to run
analytics on your data.
You've got a global
situation where
you've got an application
that needs global access.
You're going to be in the Cloud.
So I always say, if you
haven't got something already,
start with the managed service.
You don't want to set up
all of the boilerplate stuff
that you're going
to have to do to run
your own database-- the hardware
management, all the operating
system and security updates,
managing the database health
itself, making sure that
the machine is healthy.
With a managed service, all
of that's handled for you.
You don't have to do
any of that stuff.
So if you're starting
fresh, absolutely,
start with a managed service.
BRIAN DORSEY: Well, you
just set it right there.
I love it when you're
starting a new project,
and you get to set
everything up from scratch.
But a lot of us are dealing
with a lot of software
that already exists.
What do you do in that scenario?
GABE WEISS: So if you've got
one of those legacy systems,
like I said, like the
20-year application you're
working with, there's a few
different ways you could do it.
If your systems are all
really tightly integrated,
and you've got it running and
a tight cluster of machines
or something, you can just
do that, the lift and shift.
Just take the entire
thing, throw it up in a VM.
And now, instead of
running in your closet,
you're running in our closet.
But we handle all of the
machine health for you.
So that's absolutely
a valid strategy.
If you need to get out of where
you're at and get to the Cloud
first, just put everything
in a VM and get going.
You do want to split the
data out, though, right?
So strategically speaking,
if your requirements get
to the Cloud first, do that.
Lift and shift up,
then start working
on splitting of your data.
There are cases, though, where
that might not be the case.
If you've got an application
that, for compliance
reasons or other-- you have
to have the application local,
but your data has now grown
beyond where it can handle,
and you need to just
get the data out,
splitting the data out
is totally fine too.
But there's some
problems there, right?
So the internet-- the
internet's a problem, right?
So if you are in
a situation where
you want to keep
your application
but you need to move
the data, that's fine.
But you should be
aware that you'll
have to handle that on
the application side.
So great connection
to your data center.
Maybe you've got a
30-millisecond ping time round
trip.
If you're running locally,
your ping to your database
is less than a millisecond
for a really well-tuned
relational database.
So all of a sudden,
your time is 30.
But it's not even that
kind because, let's say,
for example, you're only
allowing SSL connections
to your database.
The TLS handshake to
establish that connection
takes two round
trips back and forth
to establish the handshake
before you get to the data.
So now, it's not 30
milliseconds to get your answer.
It's 100 milliseconds
to get your answer.
BRIAN DORSEY: And
then a bunch of apps
make a bunch of queries in
a row, and so that just--
every one of those
extends it out.
So what should people do
in that kind of-- what
do you do about that?
GABE WEISS: I mean, you
can't fix the internet.
The internet, you're
kind of stuck with.
But the tons of connections, the
queries that you talked about,
some applications,
because they're
used to this quick
turnaround time,
they'll just spin up a
connection, ask their question,
shut down the connection.
If you do that a couple hundred
times, and your round trip
is now not so
quick, that's going
to wreck your responsive UI.
So instead, the
first thing that I
tell people is, the first
thing you want to do
is what we call client-side
connection pooling.
Most libraries that you
connect with-- so for Python,
we recommend SQL Alchemy
is a great library
to use for connecting to
your relational databases.
There's objects that you use
to create the connection,
and there's a connection object,
and there's a pool object.
That pool is a
connection pool that
will establish-- it hands you
a connection to the database,
and it holds it open for
whatever you specify.
That means if you're making
these hundreds of queries
every second, that's great.
It'll establish one connection,
run all your queries
until there's some idle
time, then shut it down.
So that cuts down
your round-trip time
because the round-trip
time for that security
is only on that
initial connection.
And then after that,
you're good to go.
CARTER MORGAN: Right.
This is really interesting
to me because I
like that you said earlier, if
you're starting green field,
go managed.
Use the managed service.
That's the easy move.
And then I can see how it gets
a lot more complicated depending
on your needs.
The one thing I think that
shouldn't be complicated
is actually moving to the Cloud.
And so are there
tools or anything
to help make that
a smoother process?
GABE WEISS: Like you
said, it shouldn't be.
And there are absolutely
cases where it is, right?
There's totally cases where
just moving the data is hard.
One of the biggest
problems with moving
your data is-- the
boilerplate way
to do this in a lot
of cases is what
they call the export/import,
which is go to your database,
you hit a button, and it
dumps all of your data
to this giant file.
And then on the new
instance, you hit Import,
and it sucks it all into the
new one, and you're good to go.
That's the old-school classic
way that you do this stuff.
But if you've got
terabytes of data,
it's kind of tough to do that.
And while you're doing the
import, well, now what?
Unless you shut everyone
down and say, OK, no on
touch the database.
We're doing a migration.
Now, you've got data
that continues to come in
while you're importing.
So the gap between when
you've hit the export button
and when you do
the import, there's
this data that you're
missing that you
have to catch up still.
There's other ways
you can do it.
You can set up replication
between two servers, which
basically means the current
database that you're
moving away from, you
set up as the primary.
You set up a replica,
and you say, OK,
now move all the data over.
And it'll do it.
It streams it across the pipe.
It's kind of a pain to set up.
There's a bunch of little knobs.
To make that easier,
we've got a service
it's called Database
Migration Service, DMS.
And that basically handles it.
It still uses the database
native ways to do it.
So, for example, on
Postgres, we use PG Logical
as the way we do migrations.
And it will handle all
of the connections, all
the connectivity.
You define a source object,
you source database in the UI.
And then it creates a
Cloud SQL instance for you.
And then it moves it.
Now, keeping in mind, this
is only for managed service.
So if you're moving
to a managed service,
this is the tool to do it.
If you want to run your own in
a VM, you're kind of on your own
because it's not
managed for you.
So you have to do
all of these pieces.
You can still do it.
There's still ways to
set up external replicas
and external primary
instances to do it.
But you're on your own.
So DMS is the easy way to
move to a managed service.
BRIAN DORSEY: OK, that's super
cool because I have definitely
lived the try to schedule
a window where you can shut
everything down with
all the people involved,
and then hope
everything works right,
and you don't have to revert
or whatever everything.
And that's hard.
So it's nice to know
that there's some tools
to make that easier now.
CARTER MORGAN: So to summarize
what we just learned today,
just to recap everything
you came and taught,
I still want to hold up
that managed databases can
and should be used in
a lot of instances.
But there are other instances
where it doesn't make sense
to use them, where there's
some capability that you need
that's not provided
yet, or maybe just
the way your system is set up.
But if you're trying
to transfer over,
then there's Database
Management System,
which makes it a lot
smoother of a process.
Did I get that?
GABE WEISS: Exactly.
And it all comes down to
your requirements, right?
Like you said, nothing wrong
with running a database
a VM as long as you're
comfortable managing it.
If you don't want
to worry about that,
managed services are great.
BRIAN DORSEY: So if people want
to dig in and kind of learn
more about this, do you
have any recommendations?
GABE WEISS: Oh, yeah.
So the DMS, the Database
Migration Service documentation
on our site is a
great place to start.
There's a lot of
good links there.
It talks a lot about the
strategies that I talked about,
and it will lead
you into getting
comfortable with the idea
of moving your data around.
For other stuff, there's
a ton of blog posts.
We've got a lot of blog
material on our GCP blog
around v managed service
versus running your own.
There's troubleshooting.
There's a couple of ones that
are like troubleshooting.
I wrote one on connectivity.
Networking is really
hard just in general.
So I have a good
post on networking
between different services.
CARTER MORGAN: Well,
yo, thank you so much.
Thank you, Gabe, for being here.
Brian, as always, thank
you for being here.
And if you're watching
at home, leave a comment.
Let us know anything new that
you've learned or picked up.
We definitely
check the comments.
Thank you so much.
That's the end of this one.
[MUSIC PLAYING]